Add waist shaping to any sweater
with a little math and the
Knit It Now Magic formula tools.
This summer sweater has no waist shaping.
A fellow knitter, Sandy,
decided she wanted to shape her sweater
by removing a total of eight inches,
four inches from the front
and four inches from the back.
We'll create shaping
instructions in two steps.
First, after the one-inch hem, we'll start
to decrease for five inches to the waist.
For a better fit and drape, we'll knit
one inch without any shaping at the waist.
Then we'll immediately increase for five
inches back up to the bust width.
The goal is to decrease gradually from hip
to waist and then increase back
waist to bust.
We'll use the Knit It Now
Magic Formula tool for this.
Go to Patterns, Charting Tools.
Since we know our dimensions,
we'll use the Magic Formula
tool in inches or centimeters.
We will be shaping both sides
of the piece, her gage at 28 and 38.
The starting width at the hem is 18 inches
and the waist is going to be 14 inches.
The height of this section is 5 inches.
Now be sure to let the tool know if
you're working in inches or centimeters.
And click Create your
Knitting Instructions.
Here are her knitting instructions.
Draw her on and out,
you can see that there's a nice
smooth line for her sweater.
We'll do the same thing for the upper
part of this waist shaping.
Again, using the tool for both sides,
I'll enter her gage, then the starting
and ending width and height.
She will insert these instructions
when knitting the body of her sweater.
With the tool, there's
no complicated math.
Just determine the measurements you want
and create your custom
knitting instructions.